una rueda gira a 0.35 revoluciones por
segundo la relación entre el número de
revoluciones r y el número de minutos
los segundos transcurridos m se muestran
en la gráfica de abajo cuál de los
enunciados describe la relación entre
las unidades mostradas en la gráfica lo
primero que quiero hacer es ver si esta
gráfica ese sentido si es consistente
con el giro de la rueda a 0.35
revoluciones por segundo y para ver esto
dado que este eje del tiempo está en
minutos voy a transformar estas 0.35
revoluciones por segundo en revoluciones
por minuto así es que queremos convertir
0.35
revoluciones por segundo en revoluciones
por minuto es decir queremos
multiplicarlo por algo que tenga
unidades que sean segundos por minuto
para que entonces se cancelen estos
segundos y así obtenga revoluciones por
minuto pero sabemos que 60 segundos
equivalen a un minuto y aquí vemos que
dado que 60 segundos y 1 min son
esencialmente lo mismo aquí estaríamos
multiplicando por 1 al multiplicar las
0.35 revoluciones por segundo por 1
logramos que la cantidad en sí no se
altere también podemos pensar que los
estados multiplicando por 60 segundos
por minuto es equivalente y esto que nos
va a dar se cancelan los segundos y nos
queda 60 que multiplica a
0.35 y esto ya está en revoluciones por
minuto y esto cuánto nos da 60 por punto
36 por 3 18 y 60 por punto 05 equivale a
6 por punto 5 la mitad de 6 son tres más
18 que teníamos esto es igual a 21 esto
equivale a 21
revoluciones
minuto y esto es consistente con lo que
muestra la gráfica veamos después de dos
segundos deberían de ser 42 bien si está
ligeramente arriba de 40 y después de 5
segundos debería de haber girado
105 revoluciones y si está correcto así
es que la gráfica es consistente con
esta información ahora veamos cuál de
estos enunciados es correcto las
unidades de la pendiente serían las
mismas si el eje x estuviera en
revoluciones y el eje y estuviera en
minutos así que recordemos que es lo que
es la pendiente la pendiente la
pendiente se define como la razón de
cambio del eje vertical la razón de
cambio del eje y con respecto al cambio
en el eje x así que la manera como se
determina la pendiente en esta gráfica
es la razón de cambio de las
revoluciones r con respecto al cambio en
el tiempo en los minutos 9 no me gusta
usar m porque se confunde con metros
pero fue lo que usaron aquí para
designar el eje horizontal así en este
caso la pendiente es cuando ha cambiado
el tiempo en una unidad cuánto ha
cambiado el número de revoluciones
digámoslo así que ha pasado cuando ha
cambiado un minuto cuando ha cambiado el
tiempo en un minuto el número de
revoluciones han cambiado en 21 en 21
así es que la pendiente aquí es 21
revoluciones por minuto esa es la
pendiente de esta recta la pendiente de
esta recta es igual a 21 si cambiamos
los ejes si hacemos el eje vertical
tiempo y el eje horizontal revoluciones
entonces la pendiente sería el recíproco
de esto sería la razón del cambio en el
tiempo con respecto al cambio las
revoluciones sería 1 entre 21 así es que
definitivamente las unidades de la
pendiente no serían las mismas así es
que ese enunciado no aplica una gráfica
conteniendo esta información podría usar
revoluciones y horas
claro tendríamos que cambiar la escala
pero pensemos un poco en esto pensemos
en esto definitivamente si podríamos
tener una gráfica donde el tiempo el eje
horizontal estuviera en horas
actualmente tenemos 21 revoluciones por
minuto pero si lo multiplicamos por 60
vamos a tener revoluciones por hora
hagámoslo tenemos 21
revoluciones por minuto y las vamos a
multiplicar por 60 minutos que hay en
una hora y estos minutos se cancelan y
nos queda 21 por 60 veamos 20 por 60 son
1200 más 60 mil 260 revoluciones por
hora
así es que definitivamente si podríamos
construir una gráfica que contuviera esa
información si éste es nuestro eje de
horas aquí podríamos tener una hora dos
horas tres horas este es nuestro eje de
horas y aquí tendríamos revoluciones
podríamos de una escala de mil en mil
aquí tendríamos mil luego tendríamos dos
mil revoluciones
entonces cuando hay cero horas hay cero
revoluciones a una hora hay mil
doscientos sesenta revoluciones más o
menos por ahí esta sería aproximadamente
la gráfica pero lo que nos interesa es
que sí
se puede mostrar la información usando
revoluciones por hora finalmente la tasa
a la cual la rueda gira es el número de
revoluciones dividido por el número de
minutos por supuesto en este caso la
tasa dado que el eje vertical son
revoluciones y el eje horizontal son
minutos la tasa es la pendiente de la
recta por lo que la tasa de cambio de
las revoluciones con respecto al tiempo
así como está puesto en esta gráfica
está dada en revoluciones por minuto así
por ejemplo si las revoluciones cambian
de este punto a este punto de acá la
tasa de cambio sería el cambio en r el
cambio en revoluciones sobre el cambio
en el tiempo sobre el cambio en minutos
así es que es cambio en revoluciones
dividido entre cambio en minutos así es
que esta respuesta también es correcta